you are about to enjoy an experience in
extreme terror
there's no time 13 o clock hey guys its
episode 107 yeah what's this one about
we're actually doing a topic that I've
been wanting to do for a long time and
it's been a requested a couple of times
yeah I remember Armour we're doing a
whole cemetery theme yeah premature
burial yeah Body Snatchers buried alive
yeah I love this [ __ ] yeah when I was a
kid I always had like kinda this
irrational fear being buried alive I
think I saw it happening I'm horror
movie one time of it
yeah once you woke up and you were in a
casket I think that's a pretty universal
fear I mean to be honest with you and
Edgar Allan Poe put it in a bunch of his
stories so obviously it was kind of a
thing and that was a Victorian fear they
were worried about that they were and
actually um it's not a crazy fear it
does happen
personally back then especially back
then and it does happen more it's
happened more recently also which is
kind of upsetting I think I remember I
think I remember reading where at one
time or another somebody dug up some old
wrote out an old Roman coffin Rome late
Roman period yeah and had been torn up
on the inside that the person had been
buried alive and woke up I don't know
that yes but well overhearing that yeah
there's kind of a lot of stories along
that line it's like I'm willing to
concede that it's probably not as common
as people might think but I don't think
it's all that uncommon right or it's
like way more common than I'm
comfortable with I remember it being a
Roman coffin it's kind of setting off a
little bit of a [ __ ] detector
because Romans Romans didn't bury each
other they usually cremated each other
they did burials and cremation usually
the ancient Greeks and the ancient
Romans would usually leave the bodies
above ground for quite a while make sure
they were to make sure they were
because you know they didn't want that
[ __ ] to happen and I'm kind of gonna go
into that a little bit in the history of
premature burial because it's actually
really fascinating to talk about all the
premature burial burial prevention
machines yeah okay well I was gonna say
where I got a lot of the information for
the premature burial part of this show
is from this book right here which is
called I'm gonna show it which is called
buried alive yeah by Yann Banda Singh he
is a doctor and a historian and he is
fascinated with the [ __ ] in this book I
got it like at a secondhand bookstore or
something like that if you are of sort
of a morbid turn of mind as I am
this book is hella entertaining I mean
seriously I have read this book like
several times and it is so so fun I mean
it's horrifying
yeah but also kind of fun you should see
Jenny's library I mean there's more than
twice that upstairs in the attic and
storage I mean she she buys real books I
have annoying you where you gonna put
them all I have read every single one of
them yeah it's a pain in the ass when I
move but for some reason I've never
switched over to Kindle it's a good idea
like I like the idea of Kindle like if
you're traveling and stuff and you can
take a [ __ ] ton of books with you right
but if I'm gonna read a book I would
rather read a real book right even
though I read a lot of stuff online it
doesn't kind of like that with movies I
like DVDs and blu-rays I don't like yeah
my content I don't like to be dependent
on Anakin on an internet connection to
watch something yeah and then I feel
like I actually have something that I
can possess it's in my hands yeah I got
it yeah I think I feel the same way
about books and it's like you know I've
probably spent I'm sure as when
thousands and thousands of dollars many
years of books usually I get them
secondhand you know I get a book so I go
to like you know a Barnes & Noble used
to have in the front these have all
those books for like five or six bucks
like big hardback ones so I got a lot of
those too but yeah I've got shut-ins I
got all kind of stuff about [ __ ]
burial alive different kind of poisons
and healthy
but you know people people whose corpses
like you were stolen and like ended up
in different places and [ __ ] I love that
kind of [ __ ] yeah so that was that's
gonna be our topic I'll probably talk
about premature burials a little bit
first and then we'll do a little bit
about Body Snatcher sore about Burke and
Hare and what kind of NASA stuff like
that okay so the announcements we have
as I said I think I said this on the
last show that faceless villain volume
to the writing and mostly to the editing
is done yeah so what I'm doing now I'm
about halfway through like the print
layout because you know you have to put
a line everything up and just I'm doing
one more read through to make sure
there's no mistakes and then I have to
do an index and then after that I'll be
done so probably in a couple of weeks
the print version and the eBook version
will be up and then hopefully over the
next week I'm gonna start recording
right the audiobook version and then
that's got a pass that's got a pass
quality control yes yeah my it might
take an additional two or three weeks
before an audience yeah I think goes up
for sale yeah the quality control
because you have to have I'm not sure if
you guys know how this works but you
have to have the print version at least
before you can even put up the audio
Rose it has to link it to you know an
already existing work and then it has to
go through their quality control which
usually takes ten to fourteen days yeah
it yes so it generally takes about two
fries will be able to hand out free
audiobooks probably about a month yeah
I'm that easy it's probably gonna be
like I said cuz I'm really like trying
to get the version done I'm gonna upload
that as soon as it's done and then I'm
gonna discourage start recording it
right next week we're recording this on
Sunday so you know this upcoming week
which is the week of Labor Day I'm gonna
start recording the book so that should
be yeah and an audio quality will be
better of course cuz we have a much
better microphone now yeah and like I
said that's probably Breyer I'm gonna go
back and rerecord like uh some of my
older stuff and then rerecord yeah and
then actually record my fiction for the
person that's right we've been we've
been Jenny and I've been discussing how
this new fiction effort is gonna go this
is gonna be this is gonna be badass you
guys are gonna like it yeah I mean I
hope so
gonna be a bunch of collections of story
probably at least three books each and
I'm a collection of a bunch of a bunch
of stories stories novellas that were
published in other compilations by other
companies that she didn't mostly didn't
have the rights to actually sell on her
own but all it's just being freed up now
so this will save you a lot of money
don't have to hunt down all these old
collections that these companies put out
it'll be like a one-stop shop you can
get Jenny's work just directly from her
yeah so if you're interested in reading
my fiction then that's something that's
definitely gonna be coming up and
obviously the third volume of the
faceless villain I'm gonna start working
on that yeah in case you guys have never
read it in her fiction you know I I kind
of think that Jenny's a lot like Clive
Barker to me it's like a cross between
Clive Barker maybe some King kind of
thrown into wouldn't you say yeah it's
pretty gross but it's awesome
she's like I said yes weird stuff just
zombie-ism and weird sexual stuff and
that you guys will like it yeah yeah
you'll like it that's why that's why
I've been looking forward to doing yeah
and in the past it was hard to find
because most of her little short stories
ended up on these kind of obscure
collections that kind of just got sent
out into the eaten into the into the
ethos sphere wherever they were and now
they finally have the copyrights have
now gone back to you so you can you know
put it out on your own
yeah interestingly one of the short
stories that I wrote that was in a
compilation several years ago called
history is dead it was all historical
zombie stories yeah and my story that
was in there was called the anatomy
lesson and it was actually about Body
Snatcher type thing it had Rembrandt in
it it was about his painting which is
called the anatomy lesson of dr. Tulp
where they were cut and open and pulling
out the little dudes a muscle
musculature in his arm and it was kind
of from that point of view so it
actually kind of ties in with the topic
of today's show yes what what kind of
sucked the way the old media used to be
before you know the way we do things now
of course she'd cut she'd write an
awesome story and ended up being a
in a collection and that collection of
short stories all those different
authors would get like five-star ratings
but it was not her author page it was on
the page of that damn book so when it
comes to launching her own materials I
mean she's only got like one or two
reviews yeah the thing so now we have
control over her fiction yeah and I just
can now build a fiction fan base based
around Jenny Ashford now I'm thinking
you know III think like a Salesman and I
you know I know the product I know the
quality is very high and I think that
once once we start repackaging and
removing remarketing your material yeah
it's gonna it's gonna be a market
success I think for yeah I mean this is
something I've been wanting to do for a
long time just consolidating all my
fiction cuz I have so much of it laying
around it's just like some of it was
another book some of it I haven't
published and it's like so I really want
to get to a point where I can just put
all of them together like in one series
of books you know that kind of look like
I said yeah it's gonna look like a set
you know so that's kind of what I'm
gonna do after yeah faceless bill and
two comes out I'm gonna get started on
that and simultaneously rocking on
faceless ville and volume and jenny has
a good fan base for her nonfiction and
yet the nonfiction fan base is the
launching platform for the new fiction
and it'll go over well yeah so you know
if you like horror fiction and you like
someone why not fiction yeah we're gonna
give you guys free copies of it and you
guys can help her out by writing a
review yeah and also like we say every
episode if you'd like to financially
support the show you can go to our
patreon page which is patreon complex
our 10 o'clock podcast or you can go to
our blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
duck wordpress.com and there's a link in
the sidebar to a PayPal account now this
week one of our heavy hitters on patreon
Tom with an age yeah not like you know
um has actually doubled his support
heard about it yeah thank you
yeah he's so much like what 22 42 yes
yeah thank you thank you that is awesome
yeah um you know like I said any amount
you can give is fine if you want to give
once through PayPal that's fine too you
know everything helps us everything
helps us
um you know make the show better and
that's what we're trying to do and like
I said when we get to a thousand dollars
a month on patreon we're gonna start
something we're going to launch a third
weekly show yeah so we've been bouncing
some ideas around by the time that
happens we'll know when we start getting
close to that 1,000 and we'll start
getting something in the can yeah yeah
that way you know we'll test it out on
some of our subscribers to see if they
like it yeah I mean actually you know we
have some good ideas for it I think it's
gonna be fun yeah but you know if you
like the movie reviews it's gonna be
almost kind of like a combination
between like movie review type of thing
and this type of thing but yeah kind of
more more funny I guess cuz it's gonna
be fun cuz I know that like on the
Regular Show sometimes we do fun funny
topics and a lot of times we do super
bummer topics ya know this be kind of
positive and nostalgic we're gonna talk
about old stuff that used to exist and
we're you know what happened to it why
it made it or why it didn't make it I
want some good visuals I want some good
soundtracks in the back want some
favorite way of playing sometimes you
know I mean I want the music we'll have
to just fit whatever the topic is yeah
yeah I'm not gonna limit on the beat I'm
gonna do each one is like a separate
like depending on whatever the topic at
hand well be kind like a one-off yeah
yeah that's definitely what I'm
picturing right so anyway other than
that just the usual things if you want
to check out my game which is a giallo
type murder mystery somebody asked on
YouTube if you had to know about the
movies to play this game you do not it's
it helps it makes it funnier I guess I
think if you know kind of a lot of the
tropes but yeah you absolutely don't
need to know anything about the geology
onra if you know how to play clue you
can figure it out it's a very similar to
clue but also has an element of kind of
a dungeon master director type person
who like makes up a mystery and then
everybody else so is it for sale already
yes it is okay it's a and it's at the
game crafter calm I usually put a link
in the adoption remind me we got to send
a hard copy of that to beer and see see
how much money they want to [ __ ] have
a you know
mean to make an episode of I'm assuming
they charge money well you can do that
what you would do is you would send them
a copy and you would sponsor and I'm
saying sponsor an episode I'm what I
wonder how much they owe or buy them
beers I think that works as well what
are we talking about I'm not sure I have
to go we got a contact all right so
before we get into the premature burial
portion I just have to like a couple
little news stories and I wanted a
couple little recent news stories that
were cemetery related so we could do a
whole graveyard type of show which I
kind of like the idea so there are I
mean not surprisingly there aren't
really that many great related news
stories for the past couple weeks but I
did find a couple and this one happened
they are sometime between August 18th
and August 27th in Milwaukee Wisconsin
somebody went into the forest home
cemetery and stole a 6-foot bronze angel
statue from off of the Schroeder family
plot and they also took these big like 3
foot by 6 foot doors and there's like
this is heavy [ __ ] yeah and this angel
has been there it's really pretty like
I'll put pictures of it in the video but
I didn't put that in their house yeah
and I'm sitting there going and one of
the other plots nearby because
apparently there's a lot of these bronze
angel statues that have been there for
like you know decades yeah over
particular family plots because this is
like a pretty popular
you know grave marker to put on there
and they've been there for a really long
time but for some reason recently
somebody decided I'm gonna get that [ __ ]
and they drove into the cemetery the how
much does a [ __ ] six foot ain't just
this big statue and it's bronze I don't
know if it's solid it's probably Hollow
probably hollow yeah but I mean you have
to want that pretty bad yeah cuz that
would necessitate a truck I don't know
how its put into the ground I don't know
you know what I mean it's like I don't
even think it was a group effort you'd
probably need it would happen
yeah there's no way just one person you
wonder you know I could understand
somebody wanting that maybe it's a
decoration in the house but how do you
talk
four or five other guys to go man let's
go get this thing and put it in my house
it wouldn't which men these mean I
believe maybe they sold it because there
maybe there'd have to be some kind of a
monetary reward to motivate guys to go
down there and steal it it was bronze
one car yeah okay if it was solid copper
that'd be worth a lot you just didn't
just in copper itself you could melt it
down and Dan gets a sell it by the pound
that's what I was thinking but then it's
like why I don't know it just seems like
a lot of trouble and it's like here's
the thing too though if you want and I'm
not averse I wouldn't mind having some
cool like funerary statuary in the house
cuz that's kind of that's pretty cool
I'm not gonna go and steal it from a
[ __ ] graveyard go on Amazon or
something they have like they have yeah
[ __ ] like that that you can say you
stole off a grave you really want to say
that you stole and no one's gonna call
you on it it's fine so I don't
understand why you actually have to go
to a graveyard and take somebody's grave
marker I don't know it's just maybe it's
cuz I'm lazy but it just seems like to
write like you know for not much reward
unless they unless somebody wanted that
statue specifically and paid them a lot
of money to go get it
I don't really know right but yeah so
they have no idea where the [ __ ] this
these gates or this angel statue went
and so they have like all kind of you
know phone numbers you can call and [ __ ]
like that to figure out where this
because the family is kind of pissed
when I was living in Detroit I used to
live at second West Hancock down in
downtown Detroit I lived there for about
a year and a half there was a little
goth stores running around and punk rock
kids and you know we were living in this
basically an apocalyptic type situation
and some people had that kind of cool
stuff you know I mean they would grab a
stained-glass window out of a crumbling
Church somewhere and they'd have that
propped up in a corner of a house and
statues and gargoyles that came off of
crumbling buildings it's kind of cool it
looked like something out of quo
like I would do that like but you're not
stealing it Friday from something you
yeah it's basically ruins you know yeah
that's that's probably gone now meter I
saw I saw on YouTube
they're tearing most of the truck down
all the the suburbs are gone pretty much
just raised them to the ground it's it's
when it's returned back to nature
but I mean that you know if the church
is abandoned and no one's using it it's
like yeah I wouldn't be averse to going
in there and taking a stained-glass
window crap but I'm not taking it off
anybody's grave that's you know right
that is not classy not not at all so
this other cemetery story this also
happened in August now this kind of
amused me because the headline was
something like body found in cemetery
and you're like yeah no [ __ ] but no this
was a body that actually wasn't supposed
to be there that they found in a
cemetery in Santa Monica Texas now this
guy it didn't really say in the article
what the cause of death was I presume he
was murdered but they're not entirely
sure who he is they think that he might
be this fella named William bill
Costello who was last seen August the
1st at the Tiki condominiums and on
South Padre Island in Texas now this guy
was either a priest or a former priest
now evidently there was a little bit of
a scandal about him because him and this
other priest that was like a lawsuit
like a defamation lawsuit because one of
them accused the other one of assault on
one of the church students or something
like that and so there was a big lawsuit
and after this happened like this guy
who went missing like he disappeared so
now they're kind of wondering if this
dude that they found dead laying in this
graveyard in Texas is him so this the
can idea
well they they're trying they're working
on that this was a very recent I mean
this this article is only from a couple
days ago okay so they only just they're
just assuming well this is a missing
person that is you know is it only like
40 50 miles away so they're like this is
a missing person from this general area
and he looks about the same is like the
same description you know
elderly people not elderly but you know
he's an older white male 200 pounds
whatever so they think that this might
be this priest which kind of leads me to
maybe that other priest [ __ ] bumped
him off and then left him in this
[ __ ] Cemetery it's surprising to me
how few bodies are found in cemeteries
you think if you were gonna kill
somebody and then you could like dig a
hole and then bury somebody under where
they were already well there's usually a
high fence around them and there's gay
it's hard to get in there to get that
body in there I guess you can't just
walk in well anymore well there may be a
maybe an approach where you could walk
in you know going back through my memory
of all those cemeteries used to play in
up in Mississippi there might be a way
in but that's the side that's covered in
forests yeah so it means you got to
carry this pickle you got to carry this
body around everywhere and you don't
know the ages of the people involved it
might have might have been killed by
another guy who's not real physically
fit you know so yeah carry him yeah
all right so we'll kind of keep up with
that and see if that actually does end
up being that priest and if it was the
other priest that that the lawsuit was
about than actually killing him and
dumping him in the cemetery so let's see
what our where are we at time all right
so that'll do it for the news stories we
kind of kept it a little bit shorter
than usual yeah but we're gonna take a
little bit of a commercial break right
now and then when we come back we are
going to talk about premature burial and
Body Snatchers yeah so we'll be back in
just a few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and I think that's why there is so
significant because we are willing to
put pen to paper and conclude at the end
of the day at this house and we'll
continue to buddy Ginny's got some new
shirt designs up four of them really
good ones to Atlanta Ripper who put
Bello in the which out the HH Holmes
murder castle and of course demon child
cuz man said he could these are updated
designs I think they look really cool
Jenny did a great job autumn where they
found making Jenny they were very fun
and thank you very much I think they
came out very good
yeah it really good they're very high
quality shirts Jenny and I we're sure
our own shirts at certain times when
we're trying to put a spotlight on
ourselves and you can put a spotlight on
yourselves if you go ahead and pick up
on these shirts today you guys are gonna
love them links in the description
WWL comm at 13 o'clock yeah so go check
out our store at wwl com / 13 o'clock we
got these four cool new t-shirt designs
plus all our old ones if you'd rather
get one of the old ones but these ones
are awesome and you should check them
out they're also available in women's
cut they look really cute JD's got some
so thank you go check them out
okay now that we're back from the break
we're going to get into premature burial
that's the first thing we're gonna
listen we're gonna talk about all right
so the interesting thing about it as I
mentioned in the opening segment it
seems that the ancient Greeks and the
ancient Romans who are actually pretty
you know up on [ __ ] for the time yeah
they did see that there was a
possibility that you could be entombed
alive or that you could be cremated
alive so they generally had a rule I
don't think it was over the whole you
know Empire or anything like that but
they did have a general rule that bodies
should be left out for up to seven days
so you could ensure that the person was
already dead you know and it would
prevent them being buried alive or
burned alive which seems like a pretty
good option you know I got something to
say about this what's that cuz talking
talking to dr. price something came to
my mind this whole idea of being buried
alive in a tomb okay and then being
found to be alive later okay is a trope
that goes back to the the Roman Greek
and Roman period and that may have
influenced Christianity later on with
the idea that Jesus rose from the tomb
rose from the grave yeah now evidently
it was traced back to a story and I
don't remember the name of story but
somebody could check it out it was about
the a rich young girl who died on her
wedding night and was buried but it
turned out she wasn't dead she was in a
coma and when some pirates or thieves
came to loot the tomb they found that
she was alive and they took her that's
how I remembered it and then her husband
or the guy who was betrothed to her head
went out and rescued her and brought her
back and it was some kind of a Roman
tale and based on that tale they think
it became a trope this buried a live
thing well here's the thing that is a
very
a common urban legend most of the
examples stem from about the 13th or
14th century and it even has a name it's
called the lady with the ring and it's
usually a young girl a young wealthy
girl who has been buried alive that
nobody knows about from you know okay
let's see her just mentioning that you
already have that many yeah yeah oh cool
yeah it reminded me of that I don't know
if it's that old but it is a very very
common urban legend okay and the reason
they call it the lady with the ring is
because the the girl is saved by robbers
going at she's buried with a very
expensive yeah jeweled ring that's it
they break into her tomb or her coffin
and they try to cut off her finger
because they can't get the ring off and
that wakes her up and there's usually a
kind of thing to where she crawls out of
the grave
sometimes the the grave robber dies
afraid that's a pretty common thing to
happen in the story and then usually she
gets out of the grave and then walks
back to her house sometimes it's as much
as ten miles some of the stories and
goes back to her house and starts
knocking on the door and invariably her
husband or her family thinks she's a
ghost and won't let her in okay so
that's a very different very it's got
its own Wickham and today you know in
this tale started is this a Roman story
um not that I know of like I said most
of the examples of it are from the
Middle Ages and pretty much every
European country has several several
versions okay and some of them are even
associated with actual people that lived
you know whether or not that actually
happened to them they don't really think
so but like I said some myth assists
think that the Jesus story is it is was
based on these old tales it may have
been sure okay
that's something yeah no these tales go
back into Roman Greek era the
interesting thing though is that like I
said you know the Greeks in Rome and
seemed to have taken precautions against
premature burial but then you know the
when the Middle Ages came along it
seemed like I mean from from records
that still exist
it doesn't seem like during the Middle
Ages the early Middle Ages that it was
really a fear that a lot of people had
even though during the plague years it
was probably pretty [ __ ] common yes
because here's the thing you know
normally under normal circumstances your
family member would die sometimes you
would leave them in the house you know
we have a funeral or awake or it would
be a few days before they were buried
and particularly um you know in the
Jewish tradition you know you had to
wait three days before you buried them
so the problem being that when the Black
Death started spreading utter plagues
and stuff like that they didn't want to
leave the bodies hanging around in the
houses you know because of fear of
contagion and whatnot and there were so
many deaths that I'm sure it's
inevitable that many people were
probably buried alive because you know
what I mean it's you know the guys would
come by and the carts like bring out
your dead just like in the body body by
John goofy and you know and they'd be
like here just a cup they died of the
plague you know overnight just take him
and put him on the cart there are some
stories possibly true possibly not about
people waking up in the death carts or
waking up in the piece at that point
they would bury them in communal pits
because there was no way that you could
bury them all individually or have
funerals or anything like that because
there was just too many of them yeah I
remember hearing stuff you know it's
based upon evidently things were written
down at the time that there were in
certain places in certain times the
plague was so bad that whole areas of a
city and whole towns would be wiped out
oh yeah people would go there and go
where is everybody and you'd open the
doors there just be whole rotten
families yeah I'd months ago the whole
town wiped out yeah and then you just go
in the solution that they the only thing
they could do is basically I guess they
probably looted looted it you know yeah
and then burned it down to the ground
that even bury those people yeah I'm
sure they probably did because like I
said there was none of the manpower to
bury yeah it's impractical I'm like I
said even the ones that they did bury
they just had these huge communal pits
like outside of the town and they were
just put him out there on carts and just
dumped them
though they'd have coffins or like that
they were just buried in shrouds that'd
be easy just to go house for house
burning it down yeah
and like I said I mean across Europe
what was it like the Black Death that
was like a third of the population a
terribly
could you imagine that just a whole town
you lose contact with it yeah that's
during the plague and then you go there
maybe months later and you find out that
a whole town of thousands of people just
gone yeah
ghost town yeah and they're all up
indoors in bed dan imagine you're like
the last to your family you know man
yeah everybody in the damn house is dead
and you're too neat could throw them out
oh man imagine you're like a little kid
yeah I'm sure that happened I mean
everybody in the house is dead and
everybody on the entire block is dead if
they were that they had box but you know
Primus Lee yeah I guess they would have
boxed in the downtown area everybody did
and he would seem like the apocalypse
every day that's why they were gone yeah
that's why they thought it was God's
wrath and all that from because from
their point of view it would have seemed
like the end of the world if I had to
live in some past like a long time ago I
would rather go back to like ancient
Greece I would not live in the Middle
Ages no [ __ ] way because like so much
you know so much progress had been lost
like during the Middle Ages seemed like
so like I said during the Middle Ages
the early Middle Ages even though it was
probably pretty [ __ ] likely that some
people probably a lot of people got
buried alive because the plagues and you
know the fast way that they disposed of
everyone it doesn't seem like it was
that much of a fear ironically what made
it kind of a terrifying proposition all
of a sudden starting in about the 16th
17th centuries particularly in Europe
was actually the Enlightenment and the
more they do you know the kind of
progress is made in scientific and an
anatomical type of studies now it came
to light I mean before it seemed like
life and death had been a pretty
black-and-white proposition right you
were either dad or you were alive but
then as you know medical knowledge
progressed they discovered CPR
and particularly people who had drowned
and were underwater for a very long time
and then were revived and stories of
this type there was one guy I think he
was called the submarine farmer which I
kind of loved I don't know if this is a
true story but it was something that was
like kind of gained urban legend status
around Europe and he was this farmer and
he'd been working he fell through the
ice of a pond and he was evidently under
there for 16 hours into the very cold
water and he was later pulled out and
revived yeah so people were kind of like
well [ __ ] that means that you would
think that they were dead right but they
weren't they'd be back right there was
one reason I think in Japan
didn't-didn't some girl she I don't know
if there's some kind of drugs or
something but she fell unconscious
outside it's real cold they think that
she was out there dead for 20-something
hours maybe yeah and this just from
memory you know somebody might be able
to correct me and then evidently they
took her to the hospital and they just
started popping oxygen into her and gave
her some kind of blood transfusion and
she was a dead body evidently yes and
she revived yeah that's weird
it does happen evidently it changed like
a lot of definition of what death would
be yeah you know like wait a minute hold
on this person was dead yeah
they're you know and and a blood
transfusion and then pump and oxygen and
and it went on they did that to her for
a long time so we're talking it was more
than 24 hours yeah that she had yeah so
evidently been dead that's weird like I
said we got to do a show on that see if
that's true maybe that's not true
usually I have heard of people being
revived in recent times particularly if
they have been out in the cold but yeah
you know that will kind of suppress your
metabolism right you won't Rob an extent
where yeah so they can actually bring
you back and you ever see underwater you
know buried under snow things like that
I have heard of that happening I'm sure
it's it's pretty rare fairly but but
that's essentially the same thing that
happened about this time around the
enlightenment and now there was a book
written by this guy named Winslow and
evidently according to him when he was
younger
he was actually he suffered from some
type of illness that put him into some
kind of catalepsy or narcolepsy or
something like that which would put him
into these sort of trances and he
evidently was twice mistaken for dead
and you know was saved from the grave at
the last minute because he woke up so it
was something that he was really
interested in and also terrified of now
he wrote this book that was called
something like the uncertainty of signs
of life and it was a huge it made a huge
huge impact in Europe it was translated
into like five or six different language
like everyone read it it was like a huge
bestseller especially after like a
different guy who was more of a Salesman
he had written some translations of it
and went around like doing talks about
it and stuff so the whole basis of this
book was that all of the [ __ ] that they
had used previously to make sure
somebody was really dead before burying
them which usually was like they'd put
you know a mirror under your nose or
they'd put a feather under your nose to
see if you were still breathing or you
know things like that he's arguing that
these are not sufficient it's not enough
right and he and the other guy that had
picked up his work and translated into
several other languages that guy was so
into this this guy's theory in this
guy's ideas that he went back through
history and found every single story he
could find about people being buried
alive whether they were true or not he
didn't really care it was kind of like a
polemic because he was trying to you
know getting to do it so he gathered
pretty much every story to put them
together it was like I said a huge huge
success very widely read every educated
person in Europe pretty much read this
[ __ ] book and this book combined with
the invention of CPR which at that time
was kind of like a bellows where they
would kind of put it you know they'd
take out a drowned person and they would
put this bellows and like you know
artificially inflate your lungs and
people would revive so people started
you know educated people started
freaking out because they're sitting
there sinking thinking well [ __ ] if a
doctor if there's no easy way to tell
that a person is dead or if you can
bring back
person that you thought was dead and has
been laying there for hours then you
could get buried alive yeah you know it
was the next logical assumption so at
this point like during this time period
particularly in Germany this is it seems
like it really took off in Germany but
pretty much all over Europe so there was
this huge debate about how do we
determine these people are already dead
how do we determine that all of these
people have not been buried alive and
how do we prevent it from happening I
mean you had straight-up
you had like international competitions
with cash prizes where they would try to
wear like doctors and laypeople and
everybody would try to come up with
solutions to keep people from getting
buried alive like what what could they
do to ensure that this person was really
dead and I mean they came up with some
crazy [ __ ] it's like normally they would
do stuff like you know they put pins
under their fingernails or toenails um
they would cut their veins to see if
they bled they would do one very popular
one was a tobacco enema where they would
blow tobacco smoke up your ass damn they
would take a sharpened pencil and stick
it up your nose really fast they put
bugs in your ears you know they would
stick a red-hot poker up your ass yeah
um they would cut your feet with a razor
like the bottom of your feet with a
razor because I mean the horror of being
buried alive was so you know became such
a big like sensation it's funny because
in the book that I mentioned before
which is called buried alive by Yamba
dicin he said they actually did a study
of wills you know a you know of people
like making things in their wills where
they're like you know make sure I'm dead
before I get buried because I don't
wanna get buried alive because a lot of
people thought you know that's like a
fate worse than death right now he said
before this particular book came out
there was maybe he found like two wills
where people like you know we might want
to leave my body above-ground for a few
days until I start to rot before
barring me just in case he's like after
that book came out in the years after
that book came out like it the the
percentage of wills that had things like
that like please cut my head off or
something like that just to ensure
because so people were just like [ __ ]
horrified by the idea now the thing is
they're not really sure like I said I'm
sure it happens a lot more often during
times of plague during times of war you
know when there's not a lot of time to
attend to each body individually but
some of the stories that were put
forward to kind of scare people at the
time we're probably just cases of
because a lot of times they'd be like oh
we were digging up a cemetery like to
move bodies or something like that
and people were found like turned over
or you know in weird positions that
their skeleton was a weird positions or
there were scratches on the side of the
lid which in some ways could be
explained by just the natural gas
floating right because they're like you
know when you put a body in a coffin
your abdominal you know gases start to
expand and there is there are cases of
bodies straight of exploding sometimes
the coffins collapse underneath the
weight of the dirt which will you know
kind of rearrange the body parts so
they're like just you know just the fact
that the body is in a different position
than when you buried it and you could
doesn't necessarily mean you can find
this on the Internet - yeah yeah they'll
actually there's videos where people
have opened up old coffins yeah and what
you find in there is pretty damn bizarre
like yeah a guy in an old Victorian suit
and he's just green with mold but he
looks pretty intact for his whole body
yeah it's pretty damn creepy and then
the stuff in the inside of the coffin
you know all those all the little like
silk lining and everything it's all kind
of faded and rot and look and it's
pretty damn spooky yeah yeah so I think
like the ones where people were buried
and like I said I'm sure it happens it
might not have been as prevalent as
people were afraid of but I think the
more
not so much coffins but I think people
that were buried in vaults or tombs
there were a couple of pretty
well-documented cases of you know they
they would bury someone in a tomb like a
generally above-ground like a mausoleum
and then later you know years later they
would come back to put another body from
the family into the mausoleum and the
skeleton of the person would be right by
the door yeah and then there'd be like
scratches on the which obviously that
would person that part that actually had
it actually I mean like I said there are
a couple of documentaries yeah and like
I said that's that's kind of a thing
that happens with the lottie's like I
said I'm sure it's happened it had it
had to it had to happen at least once
because well they know that it's
happened a few times and they're like
not so much because if we found bodies
and weird positions and stuff but
because of a few times when they had
near misses where somebody woke up in
their coffin before they buried it you
know what I mean they were putting it in
the ground and people like hey I'm still
alive in here like they happen to wake
up so they're like how you know had that
person been buried obviously they would
have gotten buried alive because they
were still alive so it does happen and
the creepy thing too is that you may
think that this is something that
doesn't really happen anymore now that
we have embalming and all that other
kind of stuff but there are some pretty
recent there was actually yeah yeah
there's some run recent there was a case
that happened in the early 2000s I think
2002 I want to say it was in
Massachusetts now they were not buried
alive but they did wake up inside of a
body bag yeah I thought it just happened
a few weeks back where there was a
couple and somebody jumped up out of the
morgue it was an old lady oh yeah it
might have been yeah they just a couple
weeks back I was I was actually watching
a documentary about premature burial it
was a British documentary from several
years ago and there was this poor woman
on there and she evidently she had a
narcoleptic catalepsy and she would go
she periodically would pass out and go
in and for all intents and purposes
would appear dead she was actually
almost buried alive three times the
first time of which happens when she was
a teenager she was was in 1958 and she
had gone to the movies by herself to see
an Avenue
salamu me and apparently she was
laughing so hard I don't know if that's
what triggered it or not but she didn't
know she had this affliction and so she
passed out in the backseat of the in the
back row of the movie theater and then
one of the ushers found her and they
couldn't find any signs of life yeah
so they put her in the morgue and she
woke up in the yeah and the second time
it happened she woke up in the morgue
and the more door was locked so she's
like in there with all these dead bodies
like bang like oh my god well I imagine
after it happened once she was kind of
used to the possibility yeah she seemed
like kind of has again yeah she was an
older lady so she seemed not okay with
it obviously but it did happen to her
three times two times in the UK and then
later on she moved to Australia and it
happened then the sad time with that she
actually collapsed in the street and the
ambulance came to get her and her son
was nearby luckily but her son was only
15 and he came running up going no
seriously she's really not dead you know
she has this thing and he couldn't
remember his calm and [ __ ] like that and
of course the ambulance men were just
like whatever kid yeah they just thought
that he was being hysterical cuz that
was his mom and she's not really dead
she's not really dead but then you know
they got her back to the he was just
trying to get them to like pokers and
like that because if they put her in the
cold storage she would die because it
was Australia it's really hot there so
there cold storages like super super
cold so they would have put her in the
freezer and she would have died in there
but yeah so as I said so after all you
know red hot pokers up the ass all of a
sudden like sneezing powder all this
other kind of stuff and then some
enterprising people started building
things called safety coffins and these
were wonderful devices there were
actually a lot of patents for these yeah
awesome
in Europe and in the US there were some
patents for these - how popular there
were some people did buy them it never
became super widespread some of the
stuff wouldn't have worked no yeah but
there was one that I saw where it's got
it's a coffin and it's gonna have a long
tube like yeah a lot of them have
to the surface yeah all right and it was
kind of a small diameter tube yeah I
challenge you to try to breathe through
a small diet the idea was good it's
still the same as no air because what
ends up happening the idea was is that
if you woke up you would have a
breathing tube to the surface right yeah
but the problem is is you're talking
about a tube you know seven eight feet
long try to try to breathe through a
seven or eight long you it's that tube
gets filled with nothing but bad air you
don't have enough lung capacity to pull
fresh air into it yeah that's the
problem that's true so you would slowly
die anyway you would slowly asphyxiate
through that little case here's a happy
fact if you are actually buried alive in
a coffin you only have about half an
hour yeah there because a half an hour
maybe an hour um you know if you don't
panic which good luck with that
yeah thanks right if you try to struggle
and fight your way to the surface and
break it open
yeah that's what I would do that try to
kick the lid crack it and dig my way out
it doesn't really work that way it's too
much no there's too much pressure on
time it deprived I mean like I said you
know the the dirt will sometimes
collapse yeah the coffins and again it's
happened to magicians how does the
magician I was gonna say you can see
that on video captions in there a couple
of them have died doing it they're bare
and it seems it's buried [ __ ] you know
and they go oh it's good and all sudden
the grounds gone yep they're like hurry
hurry game they can never get to the guy
in time knows it's you don't her two
piles of dirt lands on your lungs you
can't breathe you don't have much time
and that's you you have a couple of
minutes tops if that happens to you yeah
they were trying to get to him in the
backhoe but he was dead by the time they
got to him yep but yeah so all of these
safety coffins like I said I love all
the because you can go if you Google it
Google safety coffin and there's all
kind of like the drawings from the
[ __ ] and he's like they were so fun
like one of them had an ejector seat
which I love but I don't think they made
any of those but someone padded that
work yeah I loved it I loved it
so most of them like you said had kind
of a tube leading up to the surface some
of them had were rigged with them hells
bells electric calls little flags on the
lights right you know later on as
time went on they had little electric
bells they had one that looked like a
kind of a little mailbox that had like a
little red flag on it they wouldn't give
up and [ __ ] like that now yeah kind of
like you wake up in the middle of the
night and hit that flag and you're like
yeah they'll be here any minute
yeah sure they'll be there yeah see
that's that was one of the problems and
why you're in a cemetery there's nobody
out here see confidence never took off
they said look we'd have to hire
somebody to watch the whole cemetery all
the time just in case like one of these
alarms went off another problem too was
that alarms yeah well because people are
like well they have to be easy to do
because you know if a person wakes up
they're gonna be panicking or they're
gonna be weak or whatever so they have
to be able to pull the alarm so a lot of
times they would tie the bells to their
hands or their feet or whatever but the
problem is when future factions begins
the body starts moving around and you
know the alarms would go off but the
person was really dead it's you know it
was just gases moving the body around so
you know that so they were too sensitive
and like I said I remember there was one
of them that had like a shaft above
where the face would be yeah but
reflective mirrors so you could so the
person could see out and you could see
the person yeah I don't know if that was
something that was ever made it was just
something they were showing on paper
yeah it's ridiculous I've heard of as it
was like a one-foot square channel to
the face of the person how do you have a
sealed coffin it doesn't work it
wouldn't work no wouldn't work well and
that was thanks go down there and get
the body that's actually one of the
things that some people propose it's
like well maybe we should make the
coffins out of glass or we should bury
them like up above the ground and then
like you know this is wrong this is
mostly in vaults and stuff yeah now one
of the most famous and like I said going
back to the original book the
uncertainty of the signs of life what
his thing was was he thought that every
country in Europe that they should build
a series of what in Germany at least
they called Waiting mortuaries yeah
which would be a building where they
would put the bodies and they would just
let them lay there and most of them were
heated so the bodies would rock faster
yeah and then that you know and they
these bodies would also just be laying
out in the open yeah
like on little slabs and they would also
have them hooked up to various bells and
alarm systems so just in case anybody
woke up right yeah now for whatever
reason the dude starts rotting you know
he's not coming back right you just let
him out there you go yeah he's stinking
bury him well and that's what Winslow
was proposing he's like he's like pretty
much the only absolutely certain like
way to know that a person is dead is
when they start decomposing so he's like
so obviously we can't do this quick
burial type of [ __ ] we have to leave
these people out until they start
rotting now he he got um you know a lot
of people liked that idea in practice
yeah really the only country that really
took it under advisement was Germany now
they built a shit-ton you know all over
the cities because a lot of people die
each day and then you have to keep him
out for about a week so there's that's a
lot of dead bodies that on the surface
yeah but even in Germany where a lot of
them were built and some of them were
actually very nice some of them still
stand obviously they're not waiting more
to raise any more they've been you know
transferred and it made into other
things but they built a hold the first
one was in buy Mart I believe and then
they had a whole bunch of other ones and
this the sad thing and this has to be
one of the shittiest jobs ever normally
I mean depending on how many corpse
chambers these places had they would
have like two guys that work like
12-hour shifts right and they could see
into all they had like windows they
could see into all the corpse chambers
some of the some of them had like a
whole ward where all the you know
corpses were in one room some of them
had like little individual chambers so
this guy who was working there couldn't
leave the building for the whole 12
hours he had to sit in this one place
actually most places they said they
didn't have chairs because they didn't
want him sitting down and falling asleep
or anything like that
so these had to stand in this [ __ ]
thing he's just watching these thicker
bodies and they're like and the problem
is you know Geno's bodies rot watching
bodies rot and you know a labor was
cheap back there was I mean there was a
lot of controversy like I said Germany
built a lot of them I believe they might
have built one in France but it was
like people thought it was a good idea
but then they're like you know we're
gonna put these they stink some people
thought that it was you know not real
dignified and even though like even in
even in parts of Germany where they
passed a law that you had to take the
body to the waiting mortuary a lot of
families wouldn't do it just because
they said you know I don't want my
relative like just lying there rotting
on a slab it's like you know it's not
the heat it's not really it's better to
get them done underneath the ground as
quick as possible yeah it's also it's a
lot more sanitary to well yeah and a lot
of people thought that too they thought
because you got flies come in yeah on a
body and then they didn't they leave and
then they go some wasn't and lands on
your food yeah and Plus at that time too
they had the whole concept of miasma
where like they thought that bad smells
in the air house like we're making you
sick so you know there was a lot of
controversy and that's why waiting
mortuaries didn't really take off
anywhere other than Germany but as I
said you know and then along so that was
like a big thing for a couple hundred
years but the whole thing is like
waiting mortuaries with all the stuff in
the Wills about like you know please cut
my head off so I don't get buried alive
or whatever really that went on until
probably the advent of what do you call
it
embalming yeah embalming yeah yeah the
advent of embalming which was summer
around the Civil War you know that when
they embalmed them to ship them on ya
survived that right so that actually
made people I mean by many people feel
better it did and it's counterintuitive
because you just think well yeah you
know I don't really want that to have
like if you're still alive because
people were also worried about being you
right dissected when they were so live
jail unconscious like since some kind of
a coma and you got involved you wouldn't
even know it no you probably won't you
wouldn't know that you were dead yeah so
that's why I mean fear of being buried
alive you know it's obviously it's a
horrible thing to happen and like I said
I can imagine like waking up in a
[ __ ] coffin and that'd be like the
worst thing ever but if you go through
the regular funerary process nowadays
there's no way that you're gonna be I
mean unless you're in some
country that doesn't involve people or
unless you dies in some [ __ ] podunk
somewhere in the country it's like if
you get embalmed you're not gonna be
alive when they put you in the ground so
don't worry about it but you know it's
just funny because like I said the this
book buried alive goes into the whole
history and like this whole it was just
a whole movement and there was just all
kinds of like books and treatises being
written about the best way to determine
whether some was still alive and try to
keep people forget it was like something
that a lot of people like activists
about because they wanted to save people
from that horrible fate and it was just
like this really interesting part of
history that I feel like isn't really
talked about all I don't really
understand really the the fascination
with trying to preserve the corpse and
bury it but you know I've seen lots of
dead bodies I've been to funerals and
look at open casket funerals not me man
when I die burn me up Kenny put me in a
little vase yes I'm not even do that
because when you get it it's like in a
little VHS box dump that thing out in
the water somewhere yeah I mean because
I don't even want any kind of haven't
seen bodies yeah I don't want mine just
sitting there like that man it's
undignified action it is kind of good I
kind of feel like the same I don't want
any kind of physical remains honestly I
would either like to be cremated or
email or I would like to be I would like
to donate my body to something because
you know I've already had an out-of-body
experience you know and I do it's funny
you know the body's not you when you're
dead you're not in there that's not you
anymore that right it's just a hut it's
a discarded shell and I don't want
people looking at that thinking that
that's me yeah before it goes into the
ground and I got put in the ground ah
yeah that's a little oh sorry there
cookie what you do yeah look she wants
to be on the show yeah what you doing on
her back on the ground where she sleeps
on her back only can if she does like a
like a little person that says she does
it I guess so she's that she's the weird
that I've ever around like weird in a
good way yeah well so since we're
talking about embalming and I talked a
little bit about dissection because not
only was there a fear that you would be
buried alive but also that you would get
dissected alive because that might
happen to you because like I said there
are some diseases that mimic death and
you know so um when actually I forgot to
mention to that another thing that kind
of contributed to the whole oh my god
I'm gonna get buried a live thing was
the invention of the stethoscope that
was also another factor that played into
but so let's talk a little bit about
body snatching now here is an
interesting topic because on the surface
it seems like a pretty horrible it seems
like a pretty horrible thing but it kind
of had a silver lining because yeah
advancements in it yeah it really in
Vance Tower understanding a lot of lives
exactly so as yucky as it seems and as
horrifying as it seems and I'm not
justifying Burke and Hare because they
were murderers but I'm just talking
about people who took dead bodies and
sold them to medical schools you know
maybe not the most honest profession but
it probably helped mankind yeah well in
a large way at that time there are a lot
of Western traditions you know kind of
linked in with religions that prevent it
the medical industry or the medical
community from getting their hands on
bodies yeah and you needed to get your
hands on these bodies to get any kind of
experience you know to create surgeons
and to understand how the human body
worked and it kind of goes without
saying but a lot of a lot of countries
kind of banned messing with bodies
because they thought it was kind of
against God type of deal well the yeah
there was a sonder ground trade where he
had doctors buying bodies that had been
exhumed by Body Snatchers you know it's
good money in it it was yeah and and
easy money it should be said yeah I mean
it gave money to guys who maybe didn't
have any other kind of skills you know
he'd go out there and steal bodies and
sell them yeah it was kind of
underground economy just because
something's illegal doesn't necessarily
it's wrong there's a lot of stuff right
and I and I feel like a lot of doctors
and Surgeons at the time really
benefited from this sort of underground
illegal
yeah country to conflict the educated
elite they proved they would kind of
prove the body-snatching because they
understood they knew that the there's in
the big picture that that need then it
had to happen they were basically trying
to keep the church happy yeah and I
think that was kind of the problem now
the thing about it is that continental
Europe seemed kind of ahead of the UK
and the American colonies at this stage
because they actually had laws where you
know it was if you had you know
criminals orphans otherwise unclaimed
bodies then those who were allowed to be
dissected they didn't have a problem
with that yeah now in the UK they had a
law I believe it was Henry the eighth's
that passed this law where they only
were the surgeon schools would only get
four bodies a year and that was from and
they had to be executed criminals yeah
that's not good those were the only
right so what they ended up having to do
is like that you know the surgeon
schools they would get this one body you
know one of their ones for the year and
then you would have to buy tickets to
this huge you know everybody's sitting
these big huge theaters and watch them
be dissected so and a lot of these I
mean it was the public but it was also
medical students now prior to you know
the the Anatomy Act which I think was
1832 somewhere around there
you actually didn't really need a
license to practice medicine really and
a lot of people that were operating on
people had never had opened a body they
had never really touched anything it
made it made sense though these were the
pioneers yeah there was no authorities
to go to when it came to Anatomy so you
had to do it yourself and he had to just
share the knobs with some guys in a
theater yeah Wow look at that so that's
that's what Long's would look like well
I mean they had books and started blank
but but still if you have to do it that
way that was basically how aviation
started to I mean it's a bunch of rich
guys trying to figure out how to get an
airplane to fly yeah whoo they're gonna
go they're gonna go to the FAA to see if
you don't have a pilot's license we
talking about there are no pilots there
are no airplanes there was no FAA there
were no pilot's license anybody could
make an airplane and anybody could fly
it yeah if you could make if you could
figure out the same thing so what are
done up happing in the UK was that a lot
of Surgeons you know they were stymied
by this body you know limit their like
obviously this isn't enough so what
these a couple of surgeons did was they
started their own private medical school
and they started paying Body Snatchers
to go and get fresh corpses from now it
should be noted that at the time
stealing a body was technically not
illegal
now messing with a grave was kind of
illegal but it was just a misdemeanor
right ironically you could steal a body
because it didn't belong to anyone
anymore however it was considered theft
if you took the burial shroud or any of
the person's stuff that was in the
coffin with them so you want an undress
someone right so they're like so what
they would do was they would take all
their clothes off and they would take
all their jewelry off and put it back in
the coffin and the you know in the
shroud or whatever because they'd get in
trouble for that
but not for sneaking weird now what they
would get in trouble for mostly is
because obviously the relatives of the
people didn't like it so sometimes you
know if there was a cemetery and people
heard about you know Body Snatchers
getting going and stealing bodies from
particular cemetery sometimes the
relatives would like to take out the
graves or whatever especially if it was
new and sometimes like if you had the
money they would do a waiting mortuary
thing like in miniature where they would
have like a little stone house and
they'd put the body in there till it
started to rot and then they would bury
it so that it wouldn't be of any use
now it should be noted that when so when
this private medical thing happened and
all these other surgeons started getting
in on it then body-snatching like almost
overnight became a hugely lucrative
business to get into
because technically you were gonna get
hanged for it right like you would for
you know breaking in those houses or
anything like that
was it really a serious penalty and
because the demand was so high I mean
bodies would bring a lot of money I mean
you get like 200 bucks like the
equivalent of like 200 bucks per body
and really it was just like a night's
work you would just kind of dig you'd
get your crew and you dig down and you
you know yeah it out of the thing
evidently had some kind of a mystique
and a mojo to it too because like
doctors and university students also
would become Body Snatchers yeah it
worked alongside them so they were kind
of like that actually happened were less
than in the UK because in the u.s. in
the colonial period and a little uh you
know more what's what I don't know but
um you know a little after that is what
the word I was trying to think of the
medical students were actually expected
to provide their own cadaver dissection
alone no so that so the teachers
wouldn't say hey go steal a body but
they'd be like BYOC bring your own you
know what I mean so you know I mean so
so they would kind of go in steel body
so the same kind of thing that was
always more prevalent in the United
States I've seen I'm I've seen
photographs from that era to here in the
oh I think there might have been photos
are here in the United States but then
they'd have them they'd all be they have
all their cadavers lined up up on these
little racks and they're cut into pieces
and they got basically it looks like a
butcher's aprons on yeah the doctors you
know they're smiling with body parts you
know
so imagine it was kind of like a
hardcore Brotherhood back in those days
well you're not stealing bodies and
having a good time and drinking and
chasing women yeah sure you know how
crazy medical stick yeah doctors know
doctors are nuts if you know any doctors
doc and a lot of doctors are not yes
they are I know but yes so like I said
so the body snatching became a huge huge
thing now as the time went on it became
kind of a big problem and people were
getting offended and [ __ ] like that so
you know at that point they start like
expanding the laws then they made it
illegal to take bodies and
all this other kind of [ __ ] now let's
talk a little bit about Birkin hair
because they are probably the most
famous body snatchers
are they started out as Body Snatchers
and then maybe say yes William Burke and
William hare yeah now how they got their
start it's okay you know happened kind
of organically this was in Edinburgh and
the two guys they actually befriended
each other they lived on the same street
one of them ran a boarding house with
his mistress now while they were running
this boarding house they had this
elderly tenant who died of natural
causes still owing them four pounds in
back rent there you go so at this point
they consult with each other and they're
like well let's go sell the body to the
anatomist and we'll recoup the money
right so they ended up doing that and
then a little while later they had
another tenant who was sick and dying
and then they figured well maybe we
should just hurry this along you know
they didn't want to wait for him to die
yeah so they said well said they just
smothered him yeah and sold it again
like I said they were making a lot of
mice they're like cha-ching you're right
so they're like well now we shouldn't
wait for elderly people we'll just
snatch people off the street or what
they would what they would normally do
is they would go to prostitutes or poor
people or whatever and they would go hey
come back to our boardinghouse and we'll
give you a drink or whatever and then
they would ply them with drink and then
they would smother them they would
usually put their hand over their face
there and so they suffocated because
then that way wouldn't mess the body up
and you couldn't really tell yeah if I
remember correctly like in adjusted
dollars a cadaver from that era was go
to was going for the equivalent of like
five to ten thousand dollars it wasn't
real short money it was a pretty good
money from whatever memory yeah I don't
know if it was that much but it was
quite a bit okay it was quite a bit
remember it was like in the hundreds and
in those days that would have been like
in the thousands of dollars yeah it was
it was a lot of money
yeah and so broken hair like I said they
kind of started getting to a point where
they they would sell all of their
cadavers to a guy named dr. Robert Knox
now it's not really known I mean I'm
sure that Knox probably figured out that
these people were killing people but
he's like well you know I
getting all these super fresh mommies
and I do need them so it's like I feel
like he probably didn't ask too many
questions about where they got them from
so yeah so Birkin hair actually ended up
that their problem was they started
getting greedy and they actually ended
up killing a prostitute and kind of like
a um like mentally challenged kind of
guy that was he had been like a he was
like a street performer and he was very
popular like a lot of people knew him he
was called daft Jamie and when he turned
up on a slab and was being dissected a
lot of medical students recognized plus
he had a club foot you know so he kind
of stood out and also when they did some
of the prostitutes a lot of the medical
students were like hey I know her yeah
where is this again this was an N
borough Scotland okay yeah so I think
these guys were operating in the
underground weren't weren't they yes
were they in the city at one point got
so filthy that they had to kind of like
make a new false road and you could go
underneath yeah yeah
and they had all these undergoes I do a
show about that X right and there was a
bunch of organized crime in there and I
know that if based on a program that I
saw there was a lot of body snatching
going on and selling dead cadavers yeah
going out of Edinboro yeah and it was
you know gangsters killing each other
you know are killing their enemies and
then instead of wasting the body I'd
sell the body well yeah I mean if you're
gonna kill him anyway you might as well
like some which like I said I guess is
what Burke and Eric I love that now the
interesting thing about Burke and Hare
is that they eventually did get caught
when two of their tenants it was like a
couple they got suspicious and wondered
where this one girl was that had been
there earlier and then she wasn't there
anymore and then when they came back and
they looked under the bed and the dead
body was there so the problem though was
that when they were brought to trial
they were pretty much able to
successfully argue that they couldn't
prove murder because like I said they
had suffocated them with just with their
hands so there wasn't really any sign
that they had been murdered
so their defense was a well they just
died of natural causes and then we just
sold them to the anatomist and bla bla
but the problem was that one
one of them was it burger hair I can't
remember but one of them turned on the
other one basically turned state's
evidence and told them everything about
it so one of them got off scot-free
I believe it was hair now he just like
took off out of the country they don't
even know what happened to him
Burk was hanged they actually think they
killed 17 16 17 people I believe he was
only convicted of 3 the ones that were
recognized the prostitute deaf Jamie and
one other person but um so he was hanged
and the judge basically said not only
you're gonna be hanged but you were
gonna be publicly dissected and then put
on display in the medical Museum so they
publicly dissected him different sources
say between 25,000 and $100,000 buddy
because everybody wanted to come see it
so everybody cheered and everything and
they actually ended up putting his
skeleton on display in the end Burrell
College we're going to still stands to
this day so you can actually go in oh
and also they made a death mask of him
which is also still there and they bound
a book in his skin that is also there so
you know that that's how bad they were
at him but the thing about the whole
Burke and Hare thing so between that
trial and between there was also this
really prevalent body snatching gang as
far as I know they didn't kill anybody
they were called the crouched gang and
they pretty much had a monopoly like in
this one area of London and they would
they actually drove the prices way up
what they would do was that if there was
another rival gang that was trying to
you know steal bodies in a particular
cemetery what they would do is they
would break into that cemetery and they
would [ __ ] it all up they would like
take all the bodies on throw them on it
so and make them useless right and then
so Watchmen would be posted at this
particular so then the other gang so
they pretty much just made a monopoly
which means that they could go to the
surgeons and ask pretty much however
they want it there's a lot of that kind
of stuff I mean even HH Holmes was
trying to get in on that yes get on that
skeleton money and the Crouch gang not
only would they sell the bodies to the
anatomist for dissection but then after
that they would take the bones and have
the bones articulated and sell them to
medical schools they would also sell the
teeth to dentists to make dentures out
of so they pretty much used every part
of the box every part of the human body
they were just like wringing every cent
they could out of out of every single
body
so between Burke and Hare and the
crouched gang finally finally in the 18
I believe it was 1832 they passed the
Anatomy Act which basically you know
caught them up with the rest of Europe
where they just said you know your
family can donate your body to science
if someone dies and they're unclaimed
then they can be donated to science and
you know whatever so it wasn't just a
case of executed criminals that you want
to get four of them or whatever so now
there was like a much larger supply just
goes to show you legalization always
results in decriminalization so they
need to do that with these drugs
legalize it patrol it and then crime
will leave yeah so yeah essentially once
the Anatomy Act was passed there was no
longer a market anymore so because they
could get all the bodies they needed so
body snatching kind of just you know it
disappeared overnight because you know
they didn't need it just think just
think about you know what a hotbed that
old situation was to promote things like
murder serial murder yeah but just you
know I mean HH Holmes a good example and
the you know these body body stealing
and body producing gangs why steal a
dead body to sell it when you can just
make a dead body in self and like I said
it the fact that Burke and Hare are the
only ones that kind of got caught or got
famous for doing that kind of [ __ ] I
mean I'm sure it was pretty widespread
because it's not much of a leap to think
hey why don't I just find like drunks or
prostitutes or people no one would miss
know them and sell their body
it's like it seems a no-brainer and that
was like back in the Oliver Twist days
man life was cheap so exactly and like I
said the good old days there wasn't a
good home that was bad back now it was
horrible bad yeah like I said I wouldn't
want it I wouldn't want to live the
Victorian in their way no [ __ ] way
that was just like a horrible horrible
but yeah so and like I said a similar
kind of thing happened in the US they
were a little bit slower but eventually
got to the point where you know they had
a similar kind of rule where you could
you know voluntarily donate your body or
they you know any anyone that was
unclaimed they could use for medical
schools and stuff like that and they
what what caused the u.s. one was all
the what they called doctors riots where
you know like I said medical students
would be stealing cadavers because they
had to because that was part of their
curriculum so they'd steal cadavers and
cut them up and then the residents would
get and normally this the sad thing too
was that they had a lot of the bodies
that they ended up stealing were slaves
or freed slaves so there was a lot of
there was kind of a racial tension going
on there too particularly in New York
which at the time was about 15% black so
so a lot of the bodies turned up being
black people they've got very very upset
about it so there were there were riots
relatives of the of the desecrated you
know the graves of people who desecrated
would kind of storm the medical schools
and beat up medical students and things
like that for stealing bodies from their
plots so so that was a similar thing it
took like a series of riots --an and
stuff like that before a law was passed
and even then it was kind of spotty
because you know laws were only passed
in particular states like at some point
I was watching a documentary earlier
today where they were just they were
digging under a part of a medical
college in Georgia I think it was and
they found a [ __ ] ton of skeletons under
there and they were able to determine
that these were all the anatomical
specimens that had been stolen because
they determined that it was from that
era where they have this one particular
slave who's he had been purchased in
order to be a Body Snatcher that was his
job and he
like a very famous Body Snatcher and so
they think that all of these bodies that
were found underneath this college were
from his era so these were probably a
lot of the bodies that he took that were
cut up and done they found them in a
basement because they said you know the
bodies would be cut up or dissected and
then they would throw all the pieces
down in the basement so they found a
shit-ton of him under the school in
Georgia and that was several years ago
but yeah so they found a lot of weird
stuff underneath universities and school
old mummies yeah yeah I guess so yeah so
all right so I guess that'll that'll do
it for our for our graveyard themed
episode this was actually kind of fun
this is a fun topic and like I said I've
read a lot about this I have the topic
bleeds into so many other time it really
does is while this was going on there
also the Wild West was happening yeah so
and you know and there was a lot of
stuff about you know life was cheap out
there too yeah and they were doing weird
medical stuff also you know snake oil
salesmen and just and stuff but like I
said it as gross as all the
body-snatching stuff is I mean I'm sure
that was a big and one point that was
made on one of these documentaries was
that back in the days when you could
only use convicted criminals bodies for
dissection they're like now there was a
law where if a woman was pregnant like a
female criminal
she couldn't be hanged so they couldn't
so so no doctors could cut up a pregnant
woman because they didn't hang any
pregnant women right so they're like if
if you know pregnant woman hadn't been
stolen from the graves that had died
then they wouldn't know anything about
our extra obstetrics or gynecology or
anything like that so in a way like it's
it's yucky and it's horrible but it had
a silver lining because it really did
progress medical knowledge to a great
degree it was a weird time it was like
cross between Mad Max and steampunk type
stuff yeah I was weird so not quite as
fun is that an Oliver Twist with much
more baggage than lice I think and yeah
I don't think I'd want to live in the
city during that era
era anyway I think I'd rather yeah
probably much better out in the
wilderness out and out in the West
somehow run around with it with Native
Americans and trapping and trading fur I
could probably deal with that more than
more than with it
bad [ __ ] yeah yeah because just the
cities were just so tightly packed and
dirty and everything like that you know
it's just immoral and corrupt and a lot
of murder going on and poverty in
terrible conditions and no thanks yeah
photographs of it yeah yeah no beautiful
buildings and everything and then you
said the people are kind of spooky
looking you know I mean you realize that
the running water that they had there
was you know infested with rotten you
know uh eels and the pipes and just
nastiness everywhere you know no no
thanks yeah lots of diseases yeah I
don't think I don't want no electricity
no oh yeah like I said all right so I
guess we're gonna wrap up this episode
remember if you enjoy the show to like
share subscribe share with all your
friends share on all your social media
it really does help us out a lot if
you'd like to financially support the
show you can go to our patreon page
which is patreon.com slash 13 o'clock
podcast and or you can go to our blog
which is 13 o'clock podcast top
WordPress comm and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account where you
may give a one-time donation if you'd
like to do that also check out our
t-shirts and our tote bag on our Zazzle
store which is as well calm slash 13
o'clock and check out our last movie
review I think I forgot to mention it
was alien and aliens yeah is our last
one also go to the game crafter comm and
look up the giallo games I'll put a link
in the description and check out my
latest game and the expansion pack is
called a crimson drop on a crystal
palette and I think that'll do it for
this episode as a rough and we will see
you next time bye
but came here what a terrible pair the
deeds will beyond belief
what underground in it but a tongue
clueless kindness feet published all the
lights from the city's poor cities Waifs
and strays gumdrop lay them on a bunk
and swallow the leaves away
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]